you need earphones you need them to
listen to music and watch movies while
you're working you need them to sound
good and have great active noise
cancellation to quieten the world around
you while you pump your tunes meet the
Jabra Elite 4. they look pretty
unassuming yes and that's the great
thing about them they're low profile and
they work and oh they work well so
what's in the box you got the case with
the butts inside a set of large and
small ear tips and a USBC to USBC cable
and they cost 160 Singapore dollars now
the case is Hardy and lightweight but it
can be quite this much magnet so keep
that in mind on to the buds they weigh
4.5 grams per bud and they have a good
size to them so it's easy to take them
out and put them back in the case the
Bots use physical buttons on the side so
that you may choose to assign whatever
functions to them such as playback
options turning on ENC and the like I do
like that they have physical buttons on
the side compared to their Touch button
counterparts because those can be a hit
or miss having something consistent is
good but being able to feel the changes
on the buds is a a lot better than
guessing battery wise you've got 5.5
hours of playback with the buds and with
the kids you have a total of 22 hours
with ANC turned on and 28 hours of
playback with EMT turned off safe to say
the battery will last you throughout
your day and through whatever you're
doing moving on to connectivity pairing
the Elite Force is relatively simple all
you got to do is take them out the case
hold both physical buttons down for
three seconds or slightly more they do
come with fast pair and Swift bear which
basically means you can make almost
instant connections with your PCS your
laptops and your mobile phones fast pair
is compatible with Android OS 6.0 and
above while Swift pad is compatible with
Windows 10 and above and lastly there's
Bluetooth multi-point which allows you
to switch between calls and apps I've
had the elite Falls as my daily drivers
and I've been on crowded trains above
and underground I've been on buses and
I've been walking a lot in crowded areas
so here's what I found it does well with
canceling out the lower frequencies
while cutting just enough of the higher
frequencies to make it an enjoyable
experience I used an iPhone 13 Pro Max
for the Elite Fours and at around 50 and
above ENT Works more audibly but when
you hit 30 and Below voices and noises
like train Chimes are more audible so at
a comfortable volume you won't be
hearing the rumbling of a train carriage
or a bus but of course loud and
high-pitched sounds will cut through and
still be heard the ENT is comfortable
compared to say the Sony
wf-1000xm3s which need to be calibrated
every time you enter new environment see
if you're going from above to
underground if not it will feel like
your eardrums are slowly being squished
you can't control the level ANC with the
Jabra through the Jabra sound Plus app
but the cool thing is you can even
choose which bud you want more favorable
EMC in Jabra has made this option
available because we do have different
levels of hearing in either ear and it's
very thoughtful instead of pressurizing
just both sides and having one side's A
and C be better than the other also if
you're reading the pins to save battery
life for the Elite Force the ear tips
provide a solid seal and they're
comfortable too it may not be ENC but
these work all in all ANC is comfortable
but obviously not as comfortable as the
Samsung Galaxy buds 2 Pros which we
reviewed by the way but this is
definitely more comfortable than the
Sony
wf-1000xm3s obviously these Sony's are
much older but Sony knows a thing or two
about building things that last and
they've been serving me reliably for the
last few years it is definitely not a
fair comparison but it is astonishing
how far the industry has come the
Jaguars are perfect for officers
especially with its tier 3 mode or
basically it's ambient mode the four
microphones on this work to give a clear
and natural sounding ambient of the
space around you and come in handy if
you want to be more aware of your
surroundings this video is brought to
you by MSI meet this
featuring the latest 12th gen Intel Core
i7 processor RTX 30 series graphics and
a 16 inch Quad HD Plus touchscreen panel
with a 360 degree hinge it lets you
unleash maximum productivity with up to
11 hours of battery life at just 2
kilograms the summit e16 flip offers
unprecedented performance and
functionality allowing you to work and
play anywhere anytime usually I'd expect
earphones and headphones to be eqed much
easier than I like pop and Hip-Hop fans
need not doing anything you guys will
love this off the bat that goes with
bass hits as well maybe boost the bass a
little bit but they work just fine for
the metal hardcore and punk fillers out
there like myself you wanna bring down
the lows just a little bit in the EQ
settings which we'll talk about later in
a bit but the neutral setting works just
fine the lows are nice and thumpy the
mids are smooth and to my ears at least
the highs are pretty much relaxed you'll
have no issues with whatever songs you
throw at these whether it's realize and
rebuilt by boundaries land Del Rey
Summertime Sadness or even stay here for
a while by 11 12. drums and bass coming
as a Punchy vocals coming clear and warm
and the strings just sound beautiful on
these you will not be disappointed about
they sound like Jabra has hit a great
balance and you don't need to tweak the
EQ that much if you're worried about
that onto the app a lot of companies
should be taking notes from the Jabra
sound plus companion app not only for
the fact that you can customize and save
your eqs which I've been complaining
about because a lot of different apps
out there don't allow you to do that but
the UI is also customizable customize
your menus layout is something you're
more comfortable with on Android you get
a little tab on the notification screen
that allows you to switch between ENT
here through and turning everything off
all together though I have not seen it
on any iOS devices yet so the Androids
have a slight Edge the EQ options are
great so far the neutral EQ is really
good enough if you want to say boost the
treble or Bass a little bit in the EQ
modifier I say go for it though I prefer
the customize my own eqs but it gets
interesting when you actually do that if
if you're on one of the preset eqs and
you want to customize it hit the reset
button and it will show a coastline of
the previous EQ which makes sense since
you're adjusting the previous EQ and of
course save them and name them now the
downsides audio drops off pretty
frequently more so in ears and more
signal interference I mean obviously but
in areas say like our office or when I'm
at home the signal does cut off pretty
frequently regardless of whether you're
using a Android or iOS device I like to
think that this is an issue that breaks
the entire true wireless earbuds
industry because it's only so much you
can do to ensure a stable Connection in
areas where there is a ton of signal
interference another thing I noticed is
that when you have these butts on and
you take them off there is no sensor to
stop playback so when I take it off
right now you can hear it over here and
the only time it will stop is when you
press the button
there you go so just keep that in mind
the next thing I have an issue with is
the case or most of the lid because it
does feel kind of fragile especially
when you're gripping it you can hear it
yeah it's not good
so I kind of wish it a more solid build
and the other thing is that it's a real
smudge magnet as you can see so get a
case when you get one besides that let's
get to the testing segment and hear how
the microphone sound like this is how
the Jabra Elite Force sound like well
they should sound clear at least that's
what Java is telling us so let us know
in the comment section below what you
think about it all right so this is how
it sounds like with the Phantom full
Bloods right beside me it is on the
highest setting right now so let me know
in the comments what you guys think of
the sound quality and how to build this
noise
all in all I think Jabra has done a good
job with Elite Force from how they've
eq'd the buds its design which is a
comfortable and secure fit seamless
connectivity and Uber customizable app
and thoughtful EQ customization ANC is
decent for the price you're getting it
at again I kind of wish the top lid
wasn't so Hollow maybe more the top the
greedy cradle or fit the button
perfectly so that the case will feel
more solid other than that that's all I
have to say about the Jabra Elite Falls
if you have any questions about them
leave them in the comment section below
and I'll do my best to get to them also
make sure to follow us on all of our
socials right here so you can keep up
with the latest news and if you like
this video make sure to like And
subscribe to us it goes a long way and
if you want to check out more stuff from
us check this out
foreign